you know I've been wondering whether I
should say this but the last time I was
up close and personal with Gary his
breath was so pleasant really I was like
well what happened amazingly fresh
Gary's so many songs have been written
about your breath and teeth and gums
that you can't get a little bit crazy
from it and Robin is here to say that
you've been working on your mouth and
you smell pretty decent look at you good
now we can only just do songs about the
size of the teeth and not the brain
point well-taken yes Michael Robin
you're obviously making that up about
Gary's breath I think you said the word
was pleasant [ __ ] here yeah wait
weren't you gonna be nice to Gary for a
week because he lost his father-in-law
and it was a pretty tragic thing
absolutely but this is a [ __ ] gorilla
a tainted infected monkey okay Howard
Howard don't don't stop him because if
you take this away from him he literally
has nothing this is a shame you're
saying Michael only has the talking
about you and her life he has two things
in his life
a typical the TV show in this that's it
that's all you have oh you have two
things like a typical on Netflix which
is going into season four big deal big
balls big lips big teeth okay big deal
big balls big teeth big lips okay so
these are that little Michael is it true
that Michael it Michael is it true that
you made fun of Gary's picture on
Instagram with his dog and you said the
dog looks scared of Gary yes look like
it was hiding from his breath thank you
for the call
and thank you for letting us know that
the moratorium is officially over thank
you